Hello Freak bitches now when I ran into
in Denver, which was a fucking fun night.
That was fun, man. It was
a fun night. You know,
Roy was there the night that
Chappelle showed up at my, uh,
late show on Friday night. And by the
way, I was watching you. So it's like,
cause I knew we were going to grow and
afterwards and have some drinks and chat
and then Chappelle came in and
at the comedy cellar in New York,
Chappelle comes in a lot, but when he
comes in and the seller, it's like, well,
he'll be on stage for seven hours.
You know what I mean? Oh yeah.
Hell go on stage sometimes for like five
hours and five hours. Five hours. Yeah.
Like regularly.
Not regularly,
but it happens like to the point where
like some dude in the back of sweeping up,
you know what I mean? It's like, yeah,
he's just on state smoking
butts doing this stuff. But uh,
so when he first got on stage, I'm like,
oh no. I looked at my girlfriend go,
we're never going out with Joe tonight.
I'm like,
we're going to be watching Chappelle
til seven in the morning, you know?
But he did, you know, he did
it like, what, 20 minutes
or something. It was cool.
He didn't do that much time. I mean,
it was the end of the show, you know,
it was late.
I guess maybe you would assume that
Denver people don't have the stamina that
New York City people have. I
think so. When he just five hours.
How many people are still there
after five hours? I'm never there,
so I couldn't tell you. I have to leave
after like an hour, but uh, wow. You know,
people will stay through the whole
thing, but like not everybody, you know?
It's so weird. Yeah. But he's, I
mean, he know he's, I don't know.
I could watch Chapelle forever. He's such
a good dude, but he definitely, like I,
I've never really hung out with him.
I've talked to him a bunch but never hung
out with him. And everyone's like, dude,
hanging out Chappelles the best.
And that night I was like,
I don't think he likes me very much.
I don't know.
We were just hanging out with me. We don't
think you like to, it just got to send,
we all went out. Yeah.
No I didn't, you know,
it was one of those things where I'm like,
every time I say like he definitely liked
my girlfriend, you know what I mean?
Like it, he was talking to her. No,
not when I just meant like he
was definitely like, I was like,
so you ever really have that where
you can't get a rhythm with someone?
I was going to be talking to
him and be like, all right,
well that story's not gonna fly. Like I
had that, like I couldn't get like, uh,
that's weird. That's your
perception. That's interesting.
Cause I think generally speaking
that nobody ever likes me. I've seen,
my perception was it was a fun night. It
was, we went bar hop, we went to these,
I've been to Denver. That's speakeasy
was credit your times? Yeah.
We went to these places that you'd go
down an alleyway, you pass a dumpster,
you go through an unmarked door and we're
in this weird secret bar and I'm like,
what is this bar man? You have
to know. What it reminded me of,
it was like that scene in Goodfellas
where he's like, you want some dresses,
Karen? She's like, no, no, no.
He said, go ahead, go down a
couple of old garage doors,
make a left and then she just drives away.
That's what it was. Everyone was like,
yeah, there's a bar. Just
keep going and make a left.
We're like down this alley or the
hackles on the back of my neck where
USC legend Joe Rogan or I'm not going
to this bar. I was going to run dude,
and he's stuck.
I'm not taking a bike that I'm thinking
of running and leaving you guys behind.
It's so fun. Yeah, it was.
It was cool though. It's fun.
We got kicked out of two places for
smoking weed to two different places.
It told you couldn't smoke week. His Day
will just spark up a joint in a regular,
people just light up a cigarette, you
know, restaurant give a shit that is,
that's a weird thing that just a,
he's like missing a,
I don't give a fuck cause like he's out,
he's got a gene like an,
I don't give a fuck gene.
He's like missing a give a
fuck. I know it's not there.
And, and uh, the, you know,
the best comics to me are the
ones who don't give a fuck. Yeah.
And that dude triple doesn't give a fuck.
So like that's why he's so good on stage
because he really doesn't give a shit.
We were out till like, well, after four
o'clock in the morning and there was a DJ,
we went to some place,
there was a DJ and uh, the,
the Dj starts playing and there's like
literally like 10 of us in this bar mic.
How's this place stay open?
It's like they were just
happy to have Chappelle there.
I think Chappelle even went
up to the DJ and was like,
and then plugged in his music. He
was like, I got this. Yeah. The Jews.
He plucked it miss the Chappelle. Yeah.
It was fucking do such a trip. Well,
Dave brings these two
huge, uh, they're like, um,
you know those, uh, Bluetooth
Speakers, a JVC Bluetooth speakers.
He's got these big boxes. Yeah. He
brings two of them. They're huge.
They're like the size of
bigger than football, right.
So he brings two of them
and their sync together.
So one's left and one's right and he'll
put them on opposite ends of his Green
Room and blare music. And I
was asking him about, I go,
why you carry these fucking
things around? He goes, Joe,
my only socializing I
do is in green rooms.
It's like the only socializing. That's the
only time I hang out with people. I go,
what do you do with those? Or I'm by
myself. I mean, I live in Dayton, Ohio.
He lives in the middle of nowhere.
On a fucking font or form. Yeah.
What a cool dude though.
He's hilarious.
He's a really unique guy and a lot of
ways. He's also, he's also just, um,
it's,
it's very impressive to see somebody
who's that like kind of legendary at stand
up and walk into a place and
people are like, Oh shit, you even,
whatever level comic is it,
Oh shit, your pals here.
And then him also just be cool. Like in
other words, he doesn't have to be cool.
Well, yeah, when he's not aloof
at all, he's super friendly. Yup.
But I think he definitely has like a
little bit of a wall up for guys like you.
Yeah. That's why when you came
up to me like, Hey, what's
going on buddy? He's like,
because I'm like, I'm not, the
dude wants my phone number.
Yeah, I got it here. Yeah,
exactly. And I'm like, I definitely
know what your phone number,
but we're just going to be
getting hammered together, man.
It might as well talk a little
bit. Yeah. Yeah. We, we, uh,
we pulled it out until like, I
left him there. I left near like,
before I left, like four, four 30. I
was like, I gotta go to Denver is a,
is a fun town.
Okay.